in a society filled with human
innovation one invention stands out
above the mall the one that has become
the obsession of the modern world
money money was not just an intervention
it was a mental revolution and created a
system of trust an elaborate tie binds
us all together it connected the world
sending merchants across continents in
search of far-off riches exchange was
the engine that drove the progress of
civilization and money was the fuel it
allowed us to specialize turning hunters
into blacksmiths artists soldiers and
kings money is what made the world
modern
[Music]
we have taken it to dizzying levels of
complexity from gold coins to bits of
information stored in the cloud the
history of money is the history of us
every coin stone and shell a symbol of
what we have value who we have served
and how our culture's evolved it has
become a language that all humans speak
this is the story of how money made us
modern how it opened the globe and
spread ideologies transforming the
ancient world into a complex
civilization of merchants mercenaries
industrialists and billionaires this is
origins
you